viva la vida
you don't actually sing the words viva
la vida in the song right is that
allowed in music to name a song or you
don't would it if it was like mama i
just killed a man it's a bohemian
rhapsody
you're right you're right you don't have
to say the title
you know because i was going like
rap city
you're so right
[Laughter]
that's why you're successful and and i
can't write a song no it was funny
because um
our label asks us to take it off the
album actually oh you are kidding i love
stories like this but but phil didn't
tell us that at the time he only told us
about six months ago at the time um
someone at the label said that you've
got to take this song off it doesn't
sound like a band when it when it
arrived i was like oh this is our best
song ever it was only because of steve
jobs steve put it in an apple commercial
which made it right a hit song you feel
up to doing this song i would love to
hear it all right i'm going to keep
quiet now
[Music]
sweep the streets i used
upon pillars of saw pillars
[Music]
[Applause]
that was the world
[Music]
our people couldn't
strength
[Music]
a shitty
for some reason
[Music]
all right go
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
rule the world
that's it that is a beautiful song man
wow
i don't want to be critical but i still
think you should have put viva la vida
in the lyrics uh
[Laughter]
where would it go howard
right at the end where would you put it
right right at the end i expected you to
go
i'm telling you it works you guys need
me in the band